On me dit souvent :
"T'arrêtes pas de critiquer dans tes vidéos,
ça veut dire que t'aimes rien ? "
Non, j'aime plein de trucs,
hein...
j'aime bien les.... le...
ça a un nom là...
Je déteste le rideau de douche qui te colle
Je déteste la pub qui se lance dans un de tes onglets
mais tu sais pas lequel...
(ordi)
*Salut, c'est julien...
D'où tu sors ?
Je vais te trouver !
Où tu es ?!
Je déteste les capsules de canette qui pètent.
Je déteste les interrupteurs
à l'extérieur des toilettes.
Euh.. faut rappuyer sur le bouton,
s'il vous plaît !
On peut techniquement les mettre à l'intérieur
alors pourquoi les mettre là où on peut te faire chier.
Je déteste travailler sur un logiciel
pendant des heures avant qu'il plante.
Et bien sûr,
tu n'as pas sauvegardé...
Non, non, non, non... !!
Je déteste quand j'attends un coup de fil important
et comme il vient pas,
je prends une douche et bien sûr,
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on m'appelle...
Ah ce rideau de merde !
Grrrr !!!
Je déteste la coupe de cheveux
après avoir porté un casque,
essayez de pécho comme ça :
tu veux sortir avec moi ?
Je déteste quand tu attends
qu'une vidéo Youtube se charge,
tu la mets en plein écran,
et ça doit recharger !
Qui est le mec chez Youtube
qui a pensé à cette fonctionnalité ?!
Un mec qui n'a pas Free visiblement.
Je déteste quand je comprends pas l'ironie.
Mec, hier soir,
j'ai vu le dernier Twilight,
mais c'est un truc de malade,
c'est une bombe ce truc,
c'est un putain de chef d'oeuvre !
Moi aussi,
j'ai adoré quand je l'ai vu.
C'est une blague !
Ouais, ouais,
c'est vrai que la fin était un peu...
Non, c'est de la merde.
Je déteste quand
je parle à quelqu'un sur Facebook,
je sais qu'il a vu mon message,
mais il ne me répond pas,
la solitude.
Je déteste les gens qui lèchent leur doigt
en passant les pages.
Ouais attends voilà, regarde !
- Juste là, tu vois ?
- Ouais, arrête.
Oui, je vois bien.
Je déteste quand
un mec relou me parle sur facebook,
sans faire exprès je clique sur sa fenêtre,
du coup,
il sait que j'ai lu son message.
Et merde !
Je déteste qu'on m'appelle quand
j'ai mon téléphone dans les mains,
(Son téléphone sonne)
du coup, je suis obligé d'attendre quelques sonneries
avant de décrocher,
(Son téléphone continue de sonner)
Ouais...
Pour pas faire le mec sans amis
qui décroche dès qu'on l'appelle...
Allo.. un ami... ouais...
tu veux qu'on fasse un truc, on va jouer ensemble.
Je déteste quand un de mes voisins
ne m'attend pas en prenant l'ascenseur.
Je déteste recevoir un SMS
et en fait, non,
c'était un mec à côté de moi !
La solitude, le retour !
Je déteste les fautes d'orthographe
dans les sous-titres de séries,
les mecs font des sous-titres de séries
toutes les semaines
mais n'ont jamais ouvert un Bescherelle.
Bon, j'avoue,
je déteste prendre l'ascenseur avec quelqu'un.
Je déteste parler à quelqu'un :
Du coup, t'as vu,
ce soir, y'a un match...
Attends, s'il te plaît, ouais...
...qui en fait était au téléphone.
Je déteste quand quelqu'un
est en train de m'écrire sur facebook puis il efface.
Que voulais-tu me dire ?!
Je ne suis pas digne de ton message, c'est ça ?!
T'es au-dessus des gens,
je veux savoir !
j'ai besoin de savoir !
Je déteste quand on lèche le couteau
avant de le remettre dans le pot de Nutella.
Tiens, à toi !
Je déteste quand on ouvre un pot de Nutella et
qu'il reste de l'aluminium sur les bords,
ça me donne envie de tout...
comme ça là...
Oui, je suis un malade mental.
Je déteste quand je tue quelqu'un et
je sais pas où cacher le corps.
Ah, ça m'énerve quand ça me fait ça !
Et toi, tu détestes quoi ?
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle